et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
guillaume rosiers vous êtes le fondateur
de kovy tracker sur twitter vous
analysez la remontée quotidienne des
chiffres liés à la vaccination en france
bonsoir à vos côtés joachim sommes
forgés et député des français établis
hors de france in style et suisso vous
êtes basé bonsoir joachim ça ne
changeait merci d'être avec nous alors
guillaume rosiers je me tourne vers vous
pour commencer par ce qu'on attendait
avec beaucoup d'impatience ce chiffre
promis par olivier ferrand c'est pas les
médias qui sont en demande de ce chiffre
c'est le ministre de la santé qui nous
l'a promis le chiffre des vaccinés
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sur ce point parce qu'on les attendait
quand même pour pour ce soir oui on
attendait évidemment avec grande
impatience les chiffres du nombre de
personnes vaccinées
et aujourd'hui j'ai appris du ministère
de la santé que 5000 personnes ont été
vaccinées uniquement sur la journée
d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'à 17 heures
les chiffres ont été arrêtés à 17 heures
donc ils sont probablement d'ores et
déjà plus élevé ça veut dire que plus de
7000 personnes ont été vaccinées depuis
le début de la campagne vaccinale
dimanche dernier donc ça veut dire en
clair qu'on ressent clairement cette
accélération promise par emmanuel macron
joachim sonne forget c'est sont des
informations qui peuvent être rassurant
tout vous trouvez un petit peu vain
cette litanie qu'on nous promet des
chiffres chaque soir du nombre de
vaccinés mais je me déplaçais de course
à l'échalote parce que simplement nous
ne sommes pas dans une situation où nous
sommes dans l'urgence extrême
les faits sont là la logistique de l'êta
invraisemblablement faillite comme elle
avait failli sur les masques et sur les
thèses de telle sorte que nous ne sommes
pas prioritaires rassemblement sur les
premiers vaccins qui sont à disposition
et qui sont sorties qui ont été
administrés massivement royaume uni en
israël dans d'autres pays je vous
précise également que la chine a
commencé à vacciner avec ses propres
vaccins depuis longtemps le problème est
pas ça c'est que vous avez deux façons
de français qui seront méfiants ils ont
raison de l'être vous avez
mais français qui sont pressés peut-être
ont-ils raison d'être aussi je ne sais
pas toujours est il que les faits sont
là ils sont tenaces alors ce temps il
devrait être utilisé non pas pour être
dans la croyance pour savoir s'il faut
croire ou novak ça ne s'agit pas d'aller
à la messe ou trois rendus ou ne pas
croire en dieu
il s'agit d'utiliser notre rationalité
on est dans le pays la raison alors
utilisons ce temps parce que ce temps
finalement je pense qu'on l'a on n'est
pas dans une urgence à la journée et on
peut se donner ce temps pour réfléchir
pour avoir un vrai débat scientifique
rationnelle sur les pour et contre de
ces différents vaccins qui je le
rappelle n'utilisent pas tous le même
principe et on peut utiliser ce temps
pour se poser les bonnes questions
notamment par exemple sur la dangerosité
potentielle pas forcément établi
pourquoi elle peut-être peut-être
existantes sur les nouveaux vaccins arn
une nouvelle technologie qui peut être
sa prometteuse mais qui présente
également des risques
guillaume rose y est vous qui est
justement le fondateur de ce koh phi
tracker vous êtes spécialisé dans ces
chiffres
qu'est ce que vous répondez à joachim
sound forge et c'est une perte de temps
n'est pas dans l'urgence qu'il faudrait
plutôt débattre au lieu de compter alors
juste je tenais à répondre on a on a un
stock suffisant de vaccins pour vacciner
plus je m'explique on a reçu 500 mille
doses le 29 décembre on a reçu 60 milles
2 le 26 décembre et on va recevoir
encore cinq cent mille doses d'ici
demain à priori ou après demain donc ça
voudra dire que d'ici la fin de semaine
on aura en stock 1 million de doses donc
de quoi vacciner à peu près de 400000 à
500000 personnes donc le stock fin de
les pays d'autres pays n'ont pas été
privilégiés par rapport à nous on a reçu
les commandes qui avaient été effectués
par l'union européenne et donc si on a
pas vacciner plus c'est par choix plutôt
pour logistique c'est par choix
puisqu'on avait décidé de vacciner
d'abord des ehpad et qui a eu quelques
lenteurs dans les ehpad donc depuis
lundi depuis hier le personnel de santé
et vacciner massivement hier on a eu
trois mille vaccination aujourd'hui 5000
enfin de 2000 vaccination hier cinq
mille aujourd'hui donc ça monte
clairement en puissance
3000 5000 son tout petit chiffre
et oui oui mais on n'a que on peut
vacciner que k
cent vingt cinq cent mille personnes
rappelle que l'objectif est de vacciner
un million de personnes d'ici à fin
janvier actuellement avec la cadence
actuelle on y sera on y serait pas du
tout puisque avec la cadence actuelle
2000 quand on n'est pas bon en maths
mais met donc à priori ça va monter en
puissance et en train de monter en
puissance et ça devrait continuer dans
les prochains jours d'après le ministre
de la santé
alors ça c'est d'après effectivement le
ministre de la santé un sous la pression
certainement dû du chef de l'état nous
dit-on en tout cas emmanuel macron a mis
un coup de pression ce week-end il
n'empêche
l'opposition elle critique je vous
propose d'écouter le patron de la région
de rente est fière qui parle être en ald
est à moi je considère que l'état est
pleinement responsable de la situation
actuelle qui est une situation
d'incompréhension
c'est un scandale d'état et jacques
hince and forget c'est une analyse que
vous partagez où les mots sont un peu
fort
écoutez elle est alors soit les
politiques font que la politique moi je
je voudrais qu'on soit dans un temps de
la réflexion on est le point de
nouvelles technologies médicales c'est
pas rien et c'est moi je crois en
l'avenir je prends la science france est
intéressant mon habitude qu'on développe
une nouvelle méthode le bouquet
quasiment une méthode de thérapie
génique t on pas peur des mots le reste
des vaccins est reine on ne déploie pas
sur la population mondiale entier donc
savoir si en france on est on est la
lanterne rouge sont les plus rapides
passer si on trouve que je valais 5000
vaccin en une journée c'est beaucoup
c'est pas assez
franchement on en a rien à faire moi ce
qui m'intéresse moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir simplement si on est
dans une situation où les français ont
le droit au débat
si le français ou le droit à une
information libre et opérer comme on
piétine et sommes très clairement à
l'heure actuelle que nous français n'ont
pas eu droit à cette information
pourquoi est ce que au lieu de de faire
les cons à deux chiffres
de combat de type jackson qui vont être
utilisés on ne va pas sur le sujet je
rappellerai par exemple que le
professeur fisher lui-même qui est le
monsieur vaccin a conduit des essais
thérapie génique dans le cas d'une
maladie qui est un peu particulière qui
est celle d'un enfant atteint d'un
déficit immunitaire sévère
et puis il a conduit ces essais avec un
certain succès et mais malheureusement
deux enfants sur 10 ont développé des
leucémies et le professeur michel
lui-même en évidence ce mécanisme qui
est à bloc à nice de mutagénèse atteint
sectionnelles c'est à dire dont le
réintégration de donna des étrangers
dans un jeune homme qui provoque des
complications certaine et donc prétendre
que disons que cet anodin de des gens et
puis c'est à rennes puis sow finalement
ce se recombiner finalement se
recombiner avec avec l'adn de l'autre
c'est ici pas de penser que les caleçons
de vérité possible c'est à dire que là
on est dans une situation tout à ça
n'arrivera pas peut-être pour le risque
est minime
nous on n'est pas un sou de penser qu'un
fragment d arn qui va rencontrer une de
ces enzymes qui sont présents dont les
rétrovirus le qu'on appelle une
transcriptase inverse puisse permettre
d'arriver à fabriquer un fragment laden
qui va lui on se doute de s'insérer dans
le génome d'os peut-être avec papa j'ai
juste donné un exemple ce type de débat
scientifique en le vulgariser on peut
tout à fait proposer aux français
aujourd'hui on fait des comptes
d'apothicaire pour savoir si le
gouvernement et trois points d'avance ou
s'il est trop tard sur sa stratégie
vaccinale
je pense qu'on prend les français pour
des imbéciles simplement si vous voulez
prendre les français pour des grandes
personnes pour des gens responsables
lors donner un consentement libre et
éclairé
on devrait être dans une situation où le
débat ne devrait pas être un débat de
chapelle de croyance ou de nos croyances
mais devrait être un débat scientifique
de son on va éduquer les gens à ces
nouvelles technologies
on va leur donner les pour et contre on
va leur expliquer le niveau de risque
parce que on a besoin de pouvoir
chacun décide et en âme et conscience
dans une balance bénéfices risques si on
doit être citons donc c'est intéressant
ce que nous dit jackie mason forget
parce que c'est vrai qu'on le rappelle
ce dernier sondage ifop publié il ya
quelques jours
58% des français qui ne veulent toujours
pas se faire vacciner c'est vrai qu'on
déplace le débat sur une guerre de
chiffres combien de vaccination la
france risée du monde
ça vous inspire quoi est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas effectivement faire
davantage de pédagogie on a oublié
peut-être ce qui inquiète le plus
une bonne partie des français
aujourd'hui oui bien sûr et je tenais à
répondre jeu qui me sont forgés parce
que il est émis des doutes quant au
vaccin arn messager moi je ne suis ni
généticien ni médecin donc je ne
parlerais absolument pas avec une
certitude mais j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'il ya un consensus de
lance d'une très très large majorité de
généticiens de médecins de scientifiques
de biologistes pour dire que le vaccin
arn messager ne présente aucun danger et
que les rênes messager et détruit très
rapidement par le corps et de façon
naturelle un élément qui n'est
naturellement dans le corps et qu'en
aucun cas ça ne peut modifier l'adn de
notre corps je tiens aussi à rappeler
qu' aucun effet grave n'a été reporté à
ce jour et que des des essais en phase
iii d'essais cliniques ont été faits sur
trente mille quarante mille patients ce
sont des chiffres considérables plus
élevé que de nombreuses autres vaccins
et qu'à ce jour aucun effet indésirable
grave n'a été reporté donc voilà je suis
un peu étonné de de scaled indiqué
joachim sont gorgés après pour en
revenir au sujet évidemment que c'est
pas rassurant qu'une majorité de
français soit réticente au vaccin
je conseille bien sûr à tout le monde de
se renseigner sur ce vaccin
moi personnellement je le fais je lis
des articles scientifiques pour essayer
de comprendre comment fonctionnent ces
vaccins je lis les données pour voir
quels sont les effets indésirables
bien sûr que si elles sont publiées et
je me renseigne surtout auprès des
personnes qui savent
généticien sur la publication sur le
serveur habituel sur lequel on trouve de
la science vous nous manque toute
l'information sur ce vaccin pas du tout
un jeu qui me savais ce que vous avez vu
que j'ai pas vu que je peux pas
librement comme ceux comme citoyen et
comme scientifique c'est pas vrai cette
littérature la dystopie toute la
littérature et qui a eu par exemple
notamment dans les discussions sur les
traitements
cette littérature police le traitement
sur le diagnostic vous l'avez tout sur l
affaire des bas pendant toute la
première période de ce qu un navire
russe sur les vaccins ces données sont
soumis à la confidentialité dans les
laboratoires on est des données qui sont
parcellaires sur les mécanismes d'action
de ce médecin sous couvert du coup du
secret industriel
donc nous n'avons pas en main les deux
mains je suis désolé on a des données
extrêmement parcellaires
donc je l'appelle pas sa conception
libre et éclairé et que vous tournez on
n'est pas vu des effets secondaires en
effet alors à anoual à deux mois du
début des vaccinations
moi je vous reparle de re combinaison
génétique est ce que vous croyez
sérieusement on observera ça dans un
délai de quelques jeux et de quelques
semaines je sais pas quand mais dans
quelques années dans quelques dizaines
d'années qu'on aura des choses alors
rocher pour le progrès je ne suis pas
pour l'utiliser mais ted
mais ce n'était donc pas les utilisent
il fait encore peu d'habitude comme un
nouveau traitement une nouvelle
méthodologie on utilise pas sur la
planète entière et on ne doute pas de
manière hasardeuse enclenchons des
stratégies vaccinales on décide d'abord
au de l'attelage puis en soute puis
telle tranche tout à l'autre
dans ce cas là je veux dire si on
voulait être pragmatique on peut aussi
dire qu'il faudrait deux autres gros
puisque le gouvernement plus à risque de
faire des copies de grabels ce sont eux
qui majoritairement se retrouvent
personnes âgées aux personnes obèses
dans les animations on ne fait pas parce
que vous avez un petit nom ça peut être
un petit peu problématique de la noce
est comme ça et on peut le comprendre
tout faire dit aussi c'était pragmatique
sous on utiliserait ce type 2
2 pour établir les priorités vaccinale
donc on voit bien tout ça est purement
politique
je passe sur les détails la logistique
ce moment-là besoin on a besoin de
cabinets étrangers représentés par des
gens non spécialiste de la logistique
pour faire le travail logistique à la
place je me sers la santé donc c'est ce
qui est annoncé dans le canard enchaîné
avec la présence de monsieur de calan
qu'on reprenne qui représente les
intérêts de du cabinet mckinsey
on va laisser le mot de la fin gay
montrozier parce que c'est quand même
dans un souci justement de transparence
et de confiance que vous avez monté
votre plateforme d'information c'est
vrai voilà on peut compter c'est ce que
dit jean kingson forget mais il
n'empêche que ça répond à une certaine
partie de l'opinion des français qui une
fois de plus en majorité ne veulent
toujours pas aujourd'hui se faire
vacciner
il est important de fournir aux français
des données claires qu'ils puissent
vérifier ce qu'on leur dit et ce sera le
mot de la fin pour vous guillaume rozier
oui c'est extrêmement important juste
pour répondre à joakim semble changer si
les personnes en ehpad et les personnes
âgées sont vaccinés en premier c'est
parce que la haute autorité de santé a
décidé de vacciner en premier parce que
un tiers des décès sont observés en
ehpad et ça représente 1% de la
population donc c'est facile de vacciner
1 % de la population c'est une minorité
et ça fera baisser les décès d'un tiers
à peu près donc c'est peu c'est pour
cette raison là maintenant je ne
souhaite pas prendre part au débat
je ne suis pas généticien je ne suis pas
médecin
mon but est uniquement d'analysé des
données de manière le plus jeune le plus
objectif possible et c'est dans cet
optique que j'ai créée kovy tracker est
donc évidemment c'est extrêmement
important d'avoir des données précises
sur la vaccination est en tout cas sur
vaccins trackers sur kobe tracker
fussible ces données de façon très
précise puisque aujourd'hui la plupart
des médecins s'accordent sur le fait que
le vaccin est la seule solution pour
arriver à bout de cette épidémie
c'est la seule solution pour atteindre
un niveau d'immunité collectif qui
permettra d'arrêter l'épidémie est donc
je suive ses chiffres de façon très
précise pour voir quelles proportions la
population est vaccinée et surtout dans
quelle tranche d'âge dans quels
départements en france et à quelle
vitesse pour essayer de pour essayer
d'anticiper l'avenir de l'épidémie merci
à tous les deux en tout cas guillaume
rozier
jean qui nous sommes forgés d'avoir été
avec nous pour débattre de cette
vaccination en france et dans le monde
pour vous en tout cas joakim sommes
forgés merci à vous